اوكرانيا تتقدم بطلب جديد للناتو
فهل سيتم قبوله؟ والكرملين
للامريكيين قطعتم الغصن الذي
تجلسون عليه ولا مجال للعودة.
وموسكو تستعرض بعضلاتها العسكرية
في المحيط الهادئ وتأمر اسطولها
برفع حالة التأهب القصوى. فما
الذي يجري؟ وبولندا تتصادم
عسكريا مع روسيا وموسكو تتوعد
بالرد. والاتحاد الاوروبي للصين
انت اخر املنا. وبكين تحضر
بالاسلحة الحية والصواريخ ورائحة
حرب جديدة تفوح في الارجاء.
مجنون كوريا الشمالية يستعيد
بعضا من عنفوان صواريخ وواشنطن
تحضر لرد عسكري والمقاومة تلجم
المحتل برد صاعق. واليمن السعيد
يقول للحرب باي باي وماكرون
يتجاهل المحتجين ويمضي في قراره
والنتيجة كارثية الصدر يعلن عن
قرار عراقي تاريخي جمد الدم في
عروق مناصريه. تقدم روسي وانسحاب
اوكراني. تضاعفت الضربات ونالت
القوات الروسية من كل حدب وصوب
في الاراضي الاوكرانية واوكرانيا
لا حول لها ولا قوة. هنا وزارة
الدفاع الروسية تصرح ان قوات
فاغنر تواصل عملياتها العسكرية
القتالية المكثفة بيد اخراج
القوات الاوكرانية من الاحياء
المركزية لمدينة باخموت. وتواصل
القوات الروسية من جميع
الاتجاهات الضغط للاستيلاء على
مدينة باخمود شرق اوكرانيا فيما
يبدو ان الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد
بات وشيكا. فهل هو كذلك وكالة
بلومبرج تو جي بتأكيدها ان بعض
حلفاء اوكرانيا الاوروبيين
يشككون في احتمالات هجومها
المضاد المتوقع ولا يقتنعون
بامكاني حدوث اختراق كبير بل هو
اعلان لفشل الهجوم قبل حتى ان
يبدأ وهنا تعلن كييف ان القوات
الروسية تنفذ يوميا في باخموت من
اربعين الى خمسين عملية اقتحام
وخمسمائة عملية قصف. لا يكادون
يصحون من ضربة حتى تنزل عليهم
التالية. فيال صعوبة اوضاعهم حيث
اعلنت وزارة الدفاع الروسية عن
تصفية اكثر من خمسمائة وخمسين
جنديا اوكرانيا وتدمير ست مسيرات
في خرسون وزبروجيا. الى ذلك قالت
الاستخبارات البريطانية ان
القوات الاوكرانية اضطرت
الانسحاب من بعض الاراضي في
مدينة باخموت. مشيرة الى تحسن
التعاون بين وزارة الدفاع
الروسية ومجموعة فاغنر. ليشير
وزير الدفاع الاوكراني الى انه
لا بديل عن انضمام بلاده الى حلف
الناتو. ومن حالة اليأس
الاوكرانية الى بصيص الامل
الاوروبي. حيث اعلنت بولندا انها
ستسلم المزيد من طائرات ميج تسعة
وعشرين الى اوكرانيا بينما اقر
مجلس الاتحاد الاوروبي تخصيص
مليار يورو بهدف دعم القوات
المسلحة الاوكرانية. وذكر المجلس
ان المبلغ سيساعد في تعويض الدول
التي تزود اوكرانيا من مخزونتها.
فيالها من خطة ذكية. الدول
الاوروبية تدعم نفسها بنفسها
ولكن مسمى دعم اوكرانيا عن اي
دعم تتحدثون. فلم يكن امام
اوروبا الا تحميل الصين مسؤوليات
كبيرة فيما يتعلق بالحرب في
اوكرانيا. حيث قال منسق الشؤون
الخارجية بالاتحاد الاوروبي
جوزيه بوريل انه سيكون من الصعب
الحفاظ على الثقة اذا لم تساهم
الصين في البحث عن حل سياسي
استنادا الى انسحاب روسيا من
الاراضي الاوكرانية. لننتقل الى
المحيط والذي لم يعد هادئا بعد
تدريبات روسية مفاجئة بدأت بناء
على اوامر الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين. هنا وزير الدفاع
الروسي سيرجي شويجو يقول ان
اسطول المحيط الهادئ كان في حالة
تأهب قصوى مضيفا ان الهدف
الرئيسي من هذا التمرين هو بناء
قدرة القوات المسلحة على مهام صد
عدوان محتمل من اتجاه المحيط
والبحر بحسب تعبيره. ليعود شويجو
وجه تصريحا شديد اللهجة نحو
بولندا بقوله ان بولندا ركزت
وحدة عسكرية جادة على الحدود مع
بيلاروسيا وهو امر لا ينبغي
نسيانه ايضا. فهل نسي البولنديون
تحذيرات موسكو ام انهم يجازفون
بمواجهة الدب الروسي؟ حال بولندا
هو ذات الحال في استونيا.
فجميعهم يتحرشوا بروسيا حيث ذكرت
الخدمة الصحفية بالمقر الرئيسي
لقوات الدفاع بان وحدة من مشاة
البحرية الامريكية وصلت الى
استونيا للتدريب المشترك
والمساهمة في التدريبات المقبلة
لمدة اربعة اشهر بما يسمى
بمناورات عاصفة الربيع واسعة
النطاق. ومن الحروب الحالية الى
معارك الاوراق المالية. حيث قال
وزير الخارجية الروسي سيرجي
لافروف انه لا مجال للعودة
فالولايات المتحدة قطعت الغصن
الذي كانت تجلس ويقصد الدولار
الامريكي. موضحا ان هروب الدول
من الاعتماد على الدولار
والاعتماد اكثر على عملاتها في
التبادلات التجارية اصبح نهجا لا
رجوع فيه. وعلى مستوى الطاقة
كشفت وكالة الطاقة الدولية ان
صادرات روسيا النفطية قفزت الى
اعلى مستوى لها في نحو ثلاث
سنوات برغم العقوبات الغربية.
فمن يعاقب من اذا? وبعيدا عن
الواقع. صرح ممثل وزيرة الخارجية
الامريكية دوريك هوجان بان
القوات الاوكرانية ستصبح اكثر
عددا وتقدما في اوروبا بعد تركيا
وستلعب كييف دورا مهما في نظام
الامن الاوروبي ليرد الكرملين
بان ذلك سيحدث ان بقي شيء اسمه
جيش اوكراني حينها اصلا. التنين
الصيني يطلق صواريخ. الاجواء
مشحونة بما يكفي والتنين الصيني
استعداده وتايوان حابسة
لانفاسها. وبعد ثلاثة ايام من
انتهاء المناورات البحرية التي
اجرتها بكين حول جزيرة تايوان.
اعلنت وزارة الدفاع الصينية انها
اجرت اختبار اعتراض صواريخ في
منتصف المسار من الارض داخل
اراضيها وحققت هدفا لاختبار
المنشود بحسب لكن ما هو الهدف يا
اصحاب العيون الضيقة? نعم.
تتسارع التطورات العسكرية
والدبلوماسية في قضية مضيق
تايوان. حيث صدرت مواقف اوروبية
تحذر من خطر التصعيد في تلك
المنطقة فمن العاصمة الصينية.
قالت وزيرة الخارجية الالمانية
انالينا بيربوك ان اي تصعيد
عسكري في مضيق تايوان سيشكل
سيناريو كارثي للعالم باسره
لاسيما ان خمسين في المائة من
التجارة العالمية تمر عبر بينما
اكد منسق السياسة الخارجية في
الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيبوريل ان
موقف الاتحاد ثابت وواضح تجاه
الالتزام بسياسة الصين الواحدة.
ودعا الجميع الى تجنب
الاستفزازات وضمان احترام
القانون الدولي بهدف الوصول الى
نظام دولي يسود فيه التعاون على
المواجهات. الاحداث والتطورات.
نشر التليفزيون الرسمي في كوريا
الشمالية مشاهد حية لاطلاق صاروخ
باليستي عبر للقارات باشراف
الزعيم كم جونغ اون. هناك دانت
الولايات المتحدة بشدة اطلاق
كوريا الشمالية الصاروخ
الباليستي طويل المدى معتبرة انه
يشكل انتهاكا فاضحا لكثير من
قرارات مجلس الامن الدولي ويزيد
التوترات بلا داع ويهدد بزعزعة
الامن في المنطقة. ليحذر البيت
الابيض من ان الولايات المتحدة
ستتخذ كل الاجراءات اللازمة
لضمان امنها وامن فتيها كوريا
الجنوبية واليابان. تعهد رئيس
حركة حماس في قطاع غزة يحيى
السنوار بتدخل المقاومة لمؤازرة
وحماية المصلين في الحرم القدسي
وقال السنوار ان الامريكيين
والاوروبيين والعرب نصحوا
اسرائيل بلجم جنودها في المسجد
الاقصى لكنها لم تستمع فجاءها رد
صاعق وفق تعبيره. في قرار مفاجئ
زعيم التيار الصدري في العراق
مقتدى الصدر انصاره باعلان تجميد
التيار الصدري عاما كاملا. قال
وزير الخارجية التركي مولود
جاووج اوغلو انه اتفق مع نظيره
المصري سامح شكري على العمل
لخارطة طريق تقود ليبيا الى
الانتخابات. بدأت في اليمن عملية
لتبادل مئات الاسرى بين اطراف
النزاع في بارقة امل جديدة تدفع
الجهود الدبلوماسية الهادفة لوضع
النزاع الدامي على طريق الحل.
واعلنت اللجنة الدولية للصليب
الاحمر بدء عملية تبادل للاسرى
بين الحكومة اليمنية والحوثيين
والتي تشمل نحو تسعمائة محتجز
وتستمر لعدة ايام. صادق المجلس
الدستوري الفرنسي على البنود
الاساسية لقانون رفع سن التقاعد.
واقر المجلس الدستوري معظم
اصلاحات نظام التقاعد بما في ذلك
رفع سن التقاعد من اثنين وستين
الى اربعة وستين عاما. والمحتجون
يملأون الشوارع فهل تعم الفوضى
فرنسا بعد هذا القرار؟ الدب
الروسي يشعل المحيط الهادئ.
برأيكم ما هي وجهة اسطول موسكو